ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
الفيلم النهارده بيحكي عن راجل
والام لطفله امها سابتها ومشيت بعد
ولادتها على طول وتبدا بقى معناته في
تربيه الطفل لوحدها لحد هنا القصه ممكن
تبان عاديه
محدوده جدا
[موسيقى]
سم الاب من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه اللي
بيشتغل عامل في محل مشروبات معروف
والقدرات العقليه محدوده جدا وعلاقته ببنت
لوسي اللي اصبح باليوم وليله مسؤول تماما
عنها بعد هجر والدتها لهم بعد الولاده
مباشره بمجرد خروجها من المستشفى وعلى قد
ما يبان في الاول انه بيعاني من مشاكل ضعف
قدرته وصعبته على تربيتها الا ان المشاهد
ما بينهم مليئه بالدف اللي بتوضح عاطفه
الابوه الغازيه اللي عندهم وخليني اقول لك
انا لحد هنا مشاكل سام لسه ما بداتتش
الصراحه فعلا بدا مع بدايه دخول لوسي
المدرسه وملاحظه مدرسينها انها قصدها ما
تتعلمش وده كان نابع من حبها الشديد جدا
لوالدها وانها مش عايزه تعمل حاجه هو ما
بيعرفش يعملها
خلال الفيلم ادت المفاجاه يلاقي نفسه
بيخسر حضانه بنته نتيجه الاحداث خارجيه
وخارجه
اسره ثانيه ولازم يواجه محاكمه واسئله
محاميين موجود واثباتات منه انه بقى اب
صالح ويقدر يقدم لوسي العنايه الكافيه
وقدر الاهتمام والرعايه اللي هي تستحق
مشاكل بينك وبين نفسك انت عارف ان اهالي
بلاغين كثير بيوجوها بس الطفل عنده سبع
سنين هيواجهها ازاي صوت المنطق المتمثل في
مسؤولين رعايه الطفل بدون شك مع حق بس صوت
العاطفه المتمثل في علاقه سام ولوسي ببعض
وتعلقهم الشديد جدا ببعض
ودي معضله الفيلم بيحلها في النهايه
باختصار شديد الممثل شامبين اداؤه التمثيل
لشخصيه سهم كان فوق المبهر من اول احساسه
بالتوها في مشاهد الفيلم الاولى وهو واقف
بلوسي مش عارف يتصرف ازاي لحد اصرار من
يرجع بنته لحضنته ثاني نظراته فرحته قله
حيلته ولحظات حزن
هي دي درجه الصدق في المشاعر اللي قدر
يوصلها للمشاهد الفيلم كان هدفه الرئيسي
يقول لك ذكائك العقل حلو بس مش كفايه يعني
مش العكس لا في الفيلم انت بتشوف نموذجين
لنوعين مختلفين تماما من البشر سم اللي
بيعاني من اضطراب عقلي لكنه في نفس الوقت
بيملكه قدر كبير جدا من الذكاء العاطفي
واللي مش بنشوفه بس معلوسي بنشوفه كمان مع
اي شخص في محيطه فمثلا من المشاهد اللي
وضحت ده بقوه كان لما ريتا المحاميه
المسؤوله عن قضيته بدات في العياطته وقالت
انها مش شخص كامل ساعتها رد فعل سام كانه
انه حضانه على قد ما يبدو للمشاهد ان ده
رد فعل مبالغ فيه شويه لكن دي فطرته ده
اللي هو بيفهمه وفي مشهد ثاني لما ريتا
كانت بتشتكي من زوجها اسامه قال لها تسيبه
بهذا القدر من السهوله سان بيتعامل مع
العلم اللي حواليه انت من شخص وجوده
مخليني غير سعيد ليه يفضل موجود في حياتي
سيبه
غير تواصل سام بالناس عن طريق انه يقول
لهم انه طلبهم كان اختياره ممتاز كمان في
مشهد ما بينه وما بين لوسي لما قدمت
مشروعها في المدرسه قدرت تشجيع ظهر لها
على عكس اباء تانيين كثيره جدا كانوا
بيعلفوا اولادهم على ابسط الغلطات واخيرا
لما لو لسه سالته انت غير الاباء الثانيين
ليه ربنا خلقك كده ولما بدا في الاعتذار
وضحت له انها مش متضايقه منه بالعكس هي
مبسوطه انه بيديها الاحساس اللي هي
محتاجاها على عكس الا بقت ثانيين اللي مش
بيعملوا كده واللي كلها مؤشرات على ذكاء
سامي العاطفيه وعلى النقيب تماما بتشوف
ريتا المحاميه الشاطره الذكيه النجاح جدا
في شغلها ولكن باقل وصفه يقال لعلاقاتها
بابنها فاشله تمام يعني ذكاءها العاطفي
والمنطقي الكبير ما اخليهاش تقدر تكون ام
من الحاج فئه لانها تفتقر للقدر الكافي من
الذكاء العاطفيه من الحاجات اللذيذه كمان
لفتت انتباهي في الفيلم هو التنوع في
الكاميرات وزوائق التصوير والاضاءات
واستخدام الموسيقى في اللحظات السعيده
هتلاقي الكاميرا قريبه
لحركه بطيئه الاضاءه مبهجه وكمان الموسيقى
تصويريه بتديك احساس خفي انك عايز تبتسم
والنقيد تماما وقت الاستجواب والمحكمه
وغيرها من المشاهد اللي بيغلب عليها
الاضاءه الزرقاء اللي بتوصل لك الاحساس
بالمود الكئيب والمسيطر على الموقع وهنا
انت بتعرف ان الفيلم الناجح ما بيقومش فقط
على ممثل شاطر لكن على كل العناصر
والادوات اللي بتكون بتخدم وبتخدم على
المشهد علشان المشاهد يعيش كل لحظه فيها
كانها حقيقيه وهمسه ادري يحقق ذهب بنجاح
تام بس هل قوه الفيلم كان في تصويره بس من
وجهه نظري انا لا قوه الفيلم كان في
العلاقات الانسانيه والحوار
الاحداث الفيلم العلاقات ما بين سام
واصحاب واللي كانوا معه خطوه بخطوه خلال
تربيه روسي وكمان الصعبه وعلاقه سام
بجارته يعني اللي كانت اول اسمه تنطقه
لوسي كده بشكل دائم حواليها ورعايتها
من خلال المحلات بشكل قوي وحتى اللي كانت
الموضوع قبل القضيه علشان بس تثبت
لزمايلها انها مش شخص عديم الاحساس ومادي
بحث وتحول بها الامر لايمان كامل بالقضيه
وارتباط شديد بسام لوسين في الحوار ما بين
الشخصيات دي كلها بيظهر ثقل فيلم ازاي كل
شخصيه مختلفه ولها بعد مختلف وازاي كلهم
قادرين يتواصلوا بثلاثه واللي معناها في
ارض محايده انا معهم وازاي كمان الحوار
وضح تطور شخصيه سام وريتا مع تطور الاحداث
وازدياد صعابتها ومن اكثر الكوتس الانتشار
ومن اكثر القوس اللي اشتهرت في الفيلم لما
قال سم لاريتا بيروت لايك وان شاء الله
بقوه مدى التحول اللي حصل في شخصيه سام
نتيجه الضغط
كل الناس محتاجه حب الحب هو اللي خلى سام
يحاول هو اللي خلاه اصحابه يساعدوك هو
اللي خلى السام والقدام مسؤولين رعايه
الطفل والاسره الراعيه لوسي يقدروا يفهموا
ويشوفوا الدنيا بعيون بعض ويوصل له مع بعض
لحل وسط في الاخر الحب مش الحل لكنه
الوسيله اللي هتساعدنا نوصل الحلقه ومش بس
الحب تقبل الاخر وتقبله الاختلافاته مش
شرط نبقى كلنا شبه بعض ولا شرط نكون
بنتصرف بنفس الطريقه ولا نتعامل بنفس
الاسلوب تقبل اختلافاتنا هيخلق مساحه تفهم
كبيره مش المفروض نحكم على الاشخاص من
مظهرهم لكن شوف جوهرهم ايه وده اللي حل
معادله الفيلم كلها حتى لو الحل من وجهه
نظر النقاد كان غير منتقيه او غير واقعي
لكنه حل انساني بحث حل رابع جميع الاطراف
العقلاني اللي مش هيقبل غير بالحلال
العقلاني والمشاهد العاطفي اللي مش هيتحمل
فراق الاب وبنته لو شفت الفيلم دلوقت قل
لي انهي مشهد في المشاهد ولا اي مدى ان هي
بالنسبه لك ولو لسه ما شفتهوش انصحك ما
تضيعش وقت اكثر من كده وتشوفه دلوقتي
واستناني الحلقه اللي جايه فيلم جديد
استماره الافلام المقدم من العربيه
[موسيقى]